para el congreso peruano martín vizcarra
mintió obstaculizó a la justicia
manipuló testigos adúltero pruebas y le
ordenó a sus colaboradoras mentirle a la
fiscalía y no solamente a esta
institución sino también al mismo
parlamento para encubrir las visitas del
cantante a richard swing al palacio de
gobierno quien venía siendo investigado
por probable actos de corrupción al
haber sido favorecido con contratos de
asesorías al ministerio de cultura de
cultura y por los que recibió un pago de
50 mil dólares para los congresistas en
los audios compromete muy seriamente en
actos ilícitos al presidente de martín
vizcarra y lo hace merecedor a ser
restituido por incapacidad moral por lo
pronto la ministra de justicia ha
anunciado que el gobierno del presidente
de martín vizcarra va a optar dos
estrategias la principal es interponer
una demanda competencial contra el
congreso ante el tribunal constitucional
para que sea esta máxima corte la que
defina si procede o no que el parlamento
lo destituya por incapacidad moral una
segunda vía es plantear una demanda
ante un juzgado esta es una medida
cautelar para que la corté interponga
una paralización a cualquier tipo de
acción del parlamento para el presidente
de martín vizcarra los audios no
constituyen ni un hecho delictivo y todo
se trataría más bien según su opinión de
un complot para sacarlo de la
presidencia un complot que él mismo ha
señalado está dirigido por algunos
congresistas y opositores a su gobierno